hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsenses.com and today i want to
talk about
the bitcoin
[Music]
i remember three years ago the bitcoin
was actually reaching 20 000
and everybody was saying come on guys
this is a bubble
this will burst and we're gonna see the
bitcoin going to zero
because the bitcoin has no value that
was what i was hearing
at work uh within my uh group of friends
everywhere and look what is happening
actually
it's actually the opposite the bitcoin
is blowing up
it's just going higher and higher so let
me have a look at the chart
so this is the bitcoin chart so when you
look at this
to be honest definitely it looks bullish
but it's not easy
to find some levels of support and
resistance
but i can tell you that if there is one
asset where it's important to use
technical analysis
it's bitcoin because of course there are
news
but most of the price is made by the
flows
by people getting in uh massively with
like
high volumes and getting out so
you really need to understand what kind
of signals is this flow of money giving
you
so first thing to do you need to go to a
logarithmic scale
why because the bitcoin level uh three
years ago
was uh 20 times less even less that's
like 20
000 times less than now so you need to
go to the
logarithmic scale then once you're in
the log scale
what do you see you look at it for the
past
say two years it's ranging
but it's not only randy actually look
guys
look guys this is not rangy this is
actually going up
since 2015 and then correcting
but once the correction has stopped
we're going higher what is telling me
that the corrective phase that we're
having here
has actually stopped trend lines
i just do a trend line here all right
and once again look how
beautiful this trendline is all right so
i didn't make it
perfectly it's something like this
so this was the first stop in 2017
when the when the bitcoin almost reached
20 000
then we had the massive correction
here it has lost you know 85
so this was kind of the bubble burst if
you can call it like this but
it didn't go to zero it it just
got back quite quickly to the levels uh
we saw at the time
so here then it goes higher you have
another
high level that you can use to actually
build a trendline
so once you have one two highs
you can draw this trend line and here
what can you see you can see that in
july 2020 at the 10 000 live
level it got broken it got broken and
since then
um as usual when the trend line is
broken
what happens what happens
always the same thing it goes higher it
comes to re-test
and and then it keeps going up and here
it's exactly what happened so this is a
daily chart
so first day it breaks it one two three
four five six days six trading days so
it's like
one week and one day later it comes
re-tested
and exactly at this level it started to
go higher so here there was a nice trade
to set up
if you miss this one it's okay it's okay
because
there are always a lot of opportunities
to enter
a trend here you had another retest
this one was a bit messy so if your stop
loss was too tight you would have been
stopped here
that's true but if you trade in the long
term
and you buy i don't know for example at
ten thousand five hundred and then you
stop yourself
at yeah you would have stopped at ten
thousand
okay but if you take one thousand point
here you can lose 1000
points to make um
i don't know maybe 5 000 you can you
know set up a trade like
you buy here you sell here and you you
your target is around here
this is a one to five risk reward trade
it's a nice trade but
i agree this one was not easy to take
there was a lot of
bear traps contained in
this area that's for sure now
what is happening it looks to me that
we are definitely going to revisit
doltham highs
so let's put a nice shunt line here
all right so we're heading here we're
heading here
should you take a short position here
maybe in the short term
but my view on this asset is actually
quite bullish because i think that
it's a currency but it's independent of
all the other currencies it doesn't
belong to any country
and there was no quantitative easing on
this currency
so somehow if our whole system
one day fails because of too much
printing because
of losing trust of markets to the
governments that would one day give back
all the money they are borrowing
then what would happen the the
currencies
that got the most inflated like the us
dollar
number one the euro as well but like the
the yen all the actually very strong
economy currencies being inflated for
the past
10 years and the bitcoin is actually a
very nice alternative
to put your money in a currency that
doesn't belong to any country
that wouldn't fail you so i understand
why this has become kind of a safe haven
a bit like gold
because it's a very nice alternative to
our
monetary system that we have built
in the past 30 40 years basically
after the bretton woods agreement
has been over i think something like
1973 i don't want to say something wrong
please correct me if
i'm wrong in the comments i think it's
something like this
then the dollar was not pegged to the
gold
and things have changed massively
because you can
print money and inflate your currency
um just by to to boost your economy
and i think that we are actually doing
something that is
a dangerous game it's good in the short
run
i don't think it's good in the long run
and i think that the bitcoin once again
is a nice alternative so i think
that we're gonna probably get rejected
at
19 500 but then we're gonna
i think break it and probably go higher
so this is my view and let me go back to
something
a bit uh longer
if i check the bitcoin since okay two or
twelves almost since inception
what do i see i see one move up one
moves down
one move up one move down and definitely
now
we are in a move up guys this is
something that you can apply to illiad
wave theory
let's do it let's do it right now so one
two three
all right four four it doesn't really
matter i prefer to put it here
four and five
this is to me what is playing out so
we're gonna have a fifth wave
and i think we're gonna have a fifth
wave because the force wave
has been broken already this downward
sloping trendline has been broken guys
it has been broken at ten thousand
retested and
since then we have a strong impulse
higher
this means to me that we are in the
fifth wave of
our move since inception
then it's going to probably correct so
where the fifth wave might be heading
as usual we're going to use fib
extensions
so film extensions either it's an
extension of the first wave or the third
wave but it needs to be a wave that
moves in the same direction
so once again for those who don't know
about iliot wave theory
uh please just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
going to receive a free
video where i explain everything about
illiot
so you're going to understand exactly
why i'm doing those things here um
i need to project the third wave of the
first wave to the fifth one
to kind of guess where we might be
heading
so i do it with the third wave because
it's the closest one
so i measure from the lowest point of
the third wave to the highest
point of the third wave and i apply it
to the bottom of my false wave
all right and this gives me some levels
that i can tell you there's going to be
some reactions i'm not saying this is
going to be the end of the move i'm just
saying you're going to have
some liquidity selling liquidity coming
here
so what are those levels the first one
is 23 000.
okay so 23 000 is going to be the first
level
because it's a one-to-one relation of
the third wave
but it's not the most likely level in a
fifth wave usually the fifth wave
is using the 1.618 ratio the golden
ratio
or even the 2.618 if the move
is strong and extended so i think those
are my levels so 35 000
or 55 000 okay
so those are my levels on bitcoin and
just using some um
time ratios i would say that usually the
fifth wave
is you know as long as the first or the
third
or something like this so the the the
first one was two years
the third one was three years so i
expect and
the the the fifth one started
one year ago six months ago so i expect
this bull market to last maybe
one or two years so something like here
so i expect we reach as i said
something around 50 000 35 40 50
something between 35 and 55 000
around the end of next year
so that's my target of bitcoin i hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please subscribe to the channel and like
the video so i'm going to do
more videos like this one and once again
stay close to show cheers guys